learning how to strengthen your knees
should be a priority for anyone
interested in
functional performance powerful legs are
key to athleticism and agility
training the knees can lead to amazing
jump height impressive running speed and
powerful kicks
if you've ever had a bad knee on the
other hand i have i had one for more
than two years
you'll know how it can affect nearly
every movement and make you feel about
20 years older
and yet knee pain is extremely common
and very misunderstood
in this post my aim is to talk you
through how to strengthen these that are
in any shape
whether you're trying to rehab or prehab
your knees and recover from injury
or build invincible knees like pneumatic
pistons
that said if you do experience knee pain
then i highly recommend that you speak
to a professional
first there are countless things that
could be causing knee pain
and there's no way to know what's
affecting you without having someone
physically present
it could even be an infection in which
case no amount of weird squats are going
to fix you
with that out of the way though on with
the weird squats
when thinking about how to strengthen
the knees we must first focus on the
muscles
surrounding the knees that means the
quads and the hamstrings the quads act
on the quadriceps tendon
which connects to the patellar kneecap
and the patella connects to the tibia
shin via the patellar tendon however
it's also important to strengthen the
tendons themselves
which is a missing component in many
training programs also important are the
glutes and smaller supporting muscles
around the ankles and hips
these help to keep the knee straight and
prevent twisting and other issues
one thing to keep in mind when trying to
prevent injury is that these muscles are
always working
for many of the muscles surrounding the
knee your daily routine is an endurance
test
accidents can therefore happen when one
of those muscles becomes fatigued
resulting in imbalances that can affect
the position of the knee or the tracking
of the kneecap
therefore to prevent injury we need to
focus on strength endurance
not just max strength finally we need to
consider the years of damage that come
from running and jumping with incorrect
form this can cause inflammation in the
tendons and wear away at the cartilage
imbalance is the key word here should
your adductors be stronger than your
abductors
your knees will cave inwards creating
the valgus knee this is not a strong
position to be squatting or landing from
a jump
and it can easily cause injury a spring
can't work properly unless it lands
exactly
straight one of the best ways to fix
this issue is by strengthening the
glutes
the gluteus maximus is responsible among
other things for external rotation of
the hip
thus it helps to keep the legs pointing
forwards during long runs
the gluteus medius meanwhile is the
prime mover when it comes to hip
abduction
moving the legs apart the gluteus
minimus is likewise a hip abductor
together with other muscles like the
tensor fasciae latae these muscles help
to keep the knee straight
and hips balanced when you're on one leg
this can also help to prevent
itb pain the iliotibial band originates
at the crest of the pelvis above the hip
and runs to the outside of the knee
it's attached to the gluteus medius
quadriceps and hamstrings
problems occur when an individual spends
all their time running in straight lines
strengthening these muscles in the
sagittal plane but don't practice any
side to side hip movement in the frontal
plane
running is not to the problem here just
running is the problem
likewise ankle and foot stability is
another component to look at if you want
to know how to strengthen your knees
ideally we want these three joints to be
stacked so that the legs can properly
absorb impact like a spring
and so that the patella can track
properly over the joint
flat feet can cause the foot to collapse
inwards for instance over pronate
which tilts and rotates the tibia
thereby misaligning the joint
even those that don't suffer from flat
feet may be hampering their knees
ability to absorb impact
wearing shoes with big cushioned soles
for example might absorb impact in the
short term
but by encouraging a heel strike they
also put the ankle far too
far forwards this means that the leg is
straight with the center of gravity
behind it
as such the knee and ankle are powerless
to flex and absorb the shock
repeatedly running like this can
gradually wear down the cartilage in the
knees
and cause other issues such as
tendinitis and shin splints
so those are the common knee problems
causing weak and painful knees
now how do you actually strengthen them
first we need to reduce imbalances and
strengthen the hips
the most popular way to do this is with
hip abduction exercises
lie on one side and raise the leg on top
into the air if you find this hard
there's a good chance that hip weakness
is a contributing factor
for your knee pain this can be effective
for reactivating the hip abductors and
improving awareness of the muscle
so that you use it more during movement
likewise it's possible to train the
flexor digitorum longus
which flexes the four smaller toes and
the flexor hallucis longus
which does the same thing for the big
toe i made a video about this and
discussed using bands for example or
simply
digging the feet into the floor but
we'll see another way to train these
muscles
that is a little less time consuming so
one great exercise you can use to
rehab or prehab the knees or just as a
warm up is knee circles and i got this
from
strength side which is a fantastic
youtube channel you should definitely
check it out so basically what you do is
you stand with your feet together
knees just slightly bent hands on the
knees and then all you're going to do
is draw little circles around
like that to make sure to go both
directions what you're doing
is just allowing the knees and the hips
to move
as they normally would in order to
adjust to the movement
of the knees and this just helps to
activate all those muscles
or that proprioception get it working
together
so that when you're running or jumping
or whatever they can do their job
and don't miss a beat generally i prefer
to train these muscles as they were
intended to be used
in the case of the hip muscles that
means stabilizing the legs
this will better train the movement
patterns we want to learn and it will
strengthen them in a useful manner
if you suffer from knee pain and you
suspect that weak hips might be
responsible
try the 100 up this exercise was created
by walter goodall george
who used the technique to become an
unbeatable long-distance runner
he also broke the world record for the
fastest mile in 1886.
the 100 up involves running or marching
on the spot with high knees
bringing them up to your chest on each
repetition we're aiming for high volume
here as the name suggests we want 100
repetitions on each side
but build up to that if it's too much to
begin with if you're in pain you can
perform this movement by slowly raising
one foot
only once the other is planted on the
ground the jogging version of the
movement is the major and the slowing
stepping version is called
the minor you can even hold on to
something for balance
as you do though focus on keeping the
hips aligned and ankle straight as much
as you can
return the foot to the same place on the
ground every time the goal is to move
with alignment throughout every step
even as you begin to fatigue this will
also develop the hip flexors and quads
oh and we want to hit the floor with the
forefoot on each rep more on that in a
moment
of course you can do the same thing when
walking simply being mindful to keep
everything aligned as possible
and as you become more confident you can
do the same thing with running two
this is the reason i always recommend
steady state running as a part of
anyone's training regime
it's not just about strengthening the
heart lowering blood pressure aiding
recovery by encouraging circulation
and improving cardiovascular endurance
although that's all very good stuff
the other thing about running is that it
is one of the most functional
fundamental movements there is
running teaches you to move your legs
properly to maintain a strong core to
relax the shoulders and to stabilize at
the hips
even if you only run once a week you'll
get these benefits and you'll feel much
stronger
while also boosting your work capacity
the real trick though
is to use trail running in minimal shoes
these are shoes with low heel to toe
drop
thin sole and wide toe box this
combination forces a four foot stride
allowing the legs to compress under the
centre of gravity as they're supposed to
at the same time the toes are able to
splay and spread to contour to the shape
of the ground underneath
trail running of course means running on
off-road terrain and those even surfaces
will even further train these muscles of
the foot and ankle
as you try and account for all the
different levels and
dips and curves while simultaneously
encouraging more natural side to side
movement
and don't just run in a straight line
weave around trees and jump over small
obstacles
again you'll need to build up to this
don't throw on a pair and then run a
marathon
but once you're confident you'll be
invincible while filming a series of
training videos for ifit this summer
i jogged around and walked the
equivalent of 54 miles that's 89
kilometers
over three consecutive days that was all
uphill through woods
on all kinds of different surfaces i did
it in vivo barefoot shoes and i felt
great
simply wearing barefoot shoes throughout
the day is an amazing passive approach
to strengthening the knees
so this way we develop resilient legs
without worrying about the tight it band
we can further avoid this by
incorporating exercises in the frontal
plane
there's the skater hop or agility ladder
on the easier end and movements like the
cossack squat on the more advanced side
of course this stuff is also fantastic
for athletes as it helps with direction
changes and weaving
acl injuries happen most often when
cutting to the side or rapidly
decelerating
the acl is a ligament in the knee and
it's one of the most common
sights of injury finally one more tool
for developing powerful hip stability
and therefore rock solid knees
is the farmer's walk this is especially
true if you use an uneven load
carrying something on one hand now your
hips need to stabilize against the
weight over a long distance
building massive strength endurance oh
and of course you can also add any
number of one-legged exercises
as we become more confident that means
things like the pistol squat
step up deep lunges i like lunge walks
and bulgarian split squat
i also recommend adding some calf
movements in there too as the
gastrocnemius actually contributes to
knee flexion
and crosses that joint of course we need
the quads hamstrings and calves together
if we want to maximally increase jump
height as well as strengthening the
muscles around the knee joint
we can also strengthen the tendons
within the knee the quadriceps tendon
and the patellar tendon
this will further reduce the risk of
injury moreover this can result in
enhanced performance for running and
jumping
as stronger tendons are able to exert
more force
so to do this we can use movements that
take the knees past the toes
strengthening the joint in the full
range of motion examples include the
bulgarian split squat
hindu squat and [ __ ] squat yes the
knees can pass the toes
and not just during a squat knees past
the toes every time you go up or down
stairs
they do it when you get up from a chair
adding resistance in this position
will only make them tougher the body has
remarkable ability to adapt
the knees no different saying that [ __ ]
squats are bad for the knees because
they put
stress on the tendon is like saying that
bicep curls are bad for the biceps
because they put stress on the bicep
that's kind of the point
but likewise if you've never done a curl
before in your life and you try and curl
30 kilograms
or you climb 50 meters of rope then
you're looking at a torn bicep
as with the bicep example the best thing
you can do is to slowly increase the
amount of weight
to thereby fortify the muscle tendon
unit against
future injury likewise if your knee is
twisted you can still cause injury
so it's a case of slowly slowly catchy
monkey we should focus on strengthening
the knee joint itself
only once it is moving in a mechanically
sound manner
of course i can't talk about the knees
coming over the toes without mentioning
the knees over toes guy himself ben
patrick
patrick is a passionate advocate for
moving the knees past the toes
which he famously does with his atg
split squat
this is a loaded split squat where the
knees come over the toes
you start with the front leg elevated
but then move to a full range of motion
as mobility improves
the great thing about this is that it
not only strengthens the knee patrick
went from a
19 inch vertical to a 42 inch but also
enhances mobility
that's because it's a weighted stretch
which by the way is also a huge benefit
of the cossack squat
i feel these two would complement each
other nicely patrick says he can now
perform scissor splits
despite never having trained for the
move he pairs this with seated good
mornings to provide the torso benefits
missing from the back squat and plenty
of other exercises
i've not done the program but i've
watched a lot of his videos and i
definitely recommend checking out his
channel
the results speak for themselves ben has
a huge number of success stories
and has helped huge numbers of people to
recover from debilitating knee pain
not to mention leaping high in the air
of course ben doesn't recommend that you
start with a split squat but instead
suggests that you start much lighter
the first progression is simply walking
backwards which you can't do without
bending the knees over the toes
ben suggests that you cumulatively build
up to 100 miles of backward walking
later you can add resistance by pushing
a sled or dragging a sandbag
which is my favorite option this is a
concentric only exercise
it's not loaded so it's very safe and
gentle two options that i personally
recommend
are the hindu squats for high repetition
and bunny hops
hindu squats are squats performed on the
balls of the feet do a hundred of these
and feel the quad burn
bunny hops are a traveling exercise that
involve bouncing along the ground with
the legs bent
this builds that elastic springiness
that you really need for great jumping
i got this tip from vava fitness which
is another great channel you should
check out
one of the key aspects of all these
strategies is the high volume
remember the body is designed to adapt
to the environment it's placed in
when you train you're fighting your main
stimuli your daily habits
to trigger change that you don't
technically need this is why simply
avoiding
moving a painful joint is a huge mistake
as you aren't creating a need for the
body to get healthy
moving as much as you can comfortably
and then gradually building on that
is a far better approach performing a
few lateral leg raises with a resistance
band each week
is only going to do so much if you've
been forming bad movement habits
for years and years or just not moving
at all
but dedicating yourself to walking five
miles a day while being mindful of your
form
is a whole different story likewise
performing 100 daily hindu squats
likewise 100 miles backwards over time
likewise performing 100 ups
or bunny hopping to the shops that
repetition forces the brain to practice
and reinforce crucial neural pathways
it builds connections between muscles
via changes in the fascia
and it supplies those more often used
muscles with increased blood flow
that alone is why low intensity high
repetition is so effective at healing
damaged tissue
it floods the area with blood oxygen and
nutrients
after a tough workout a gentle walk is
one of the best things you can do
to encourage recovery unless you'll
actually see profound changes to your
physique and your motor patterns
and it's from here that you can begin to
safely add weight explosive movements
and challenge
you must become functional before you
can become
super functional so i hope you found
this video useful and interesting guys
if you did then
please leave a like and share it around
that helps me out immensely
let me know in the comments down below
if there's anything i've missed if
you've ever dealt with knee pain and
what you did
to recover from it if you want to become
more functional and learn more about
moving in
healthy patterns in a wide variety of
different modalities
then check out my new book functional
training and beyond which is out now in
the us
and out very soon in the uk and europe
you can get it from amazon and pretty
much any other bookstore and i'll leave
some links to that in the description
down below
thank you so much to everyone who's
bought a copy and reviewed it reviews
help
massively on amazon so that means a
great deal alternatively if you're ready
to start training then i have a full
ebook and training program
super functional training that combines
countless different ideas from different
forms of training
into a single program that you can start
using today you get a written workout as
well as lots of information
to explain what everything does and how
to adapt it to your own lifestyle and
training
there's a discount on that right now
whilst many of us are in lockdown still
so if you're interested check out the
link in the description down below
subscribe if you want more like this hit
the bell button if you want to be
notified of new videos
and i'll see you next time thanks so
much for watching this one
and bye for now